ma question porte sur les turbulences
récentes mais forte que traverse le
groupe renault déjà ébranlé par
plusieurs mois de tensions à la suite du
départ rocambolesque de carlos ghosn
l'alliance est de nouveau éprouvé par la
discussion pire leur très apparents ou
retrait réel vous nous direz d'une offre
de fusion faite par le groupe fiat
la compétitivité la conquête
d'opportunités de renault ont toujours
été au travers des différents
gouvernements une propres priorités
industriel et stratégique pour notre
pays offre un potentiel rapprochement
pour le moins précipitée avec fiat
n'aurait probablement pas rempli ses
objectifs
la proposition de fiat s'appuyait sur
une valorisation au rabais de renault
donne ait les coudées franches à la
famille agnelli dans une gouvernance
d'une nouvelle entité et / de la part de
l'état dans l'actionnariat au delà de ce
deal enterré peut-être aussi
soudainement qu'il a été envisagé je
souhaiterais que vous nous éclairer sur
les opportunités que vous pourriez
encore voir à cette éventuelle alliance
entre les deux constructeurs qui sont
assez similaires deux constructeurs qui
chasse souvent sur les mêmes zones
géographiques et sur les mêmes gammes de
voitures mais sur les risques aussi en
matière d'emploi de gouvernance
d'alliance pouvez vous nous indiquer si
vous poursuivez officiellement ou pas
avec le groupe renault la discussion
quelles seraient vos conditions pour un
accord et quelles garanties vous
pourriez demander enfin il n'est pas
impossible que ces allers-retours avec
fiat met en péril l'alliance entre
renault et nissan
la tiédeur denis salle devrait
d'ailleurs nous inviter à la prudence le
groupe japonais s'était abstenu je le
rappel du vote au sujet de la fusion
le ministre le maire s'est rendu au
japon la semaine dernière à l'occasion
du g20 finances pour tenter d'apaiser
les relations entre les deux groupes et
nissan qui tiendra le 25 juin prochain
son assemblée générale vient d'apprendre
par un courrier
renault que renault s'opposait à la
nouvelle gouvernance du groupe japonais
comment entendons nous nous etat
actionnaire soutenir le groupe renault
pour sortir du blocage actuel et
rétablir un dialogue de qualité
constructif au sein de l'alliance je
vous remercie pour vos réponses la
parole est à madame agnès pas guéri
nature secrète heures près du ministre
de l'économie et des finances ronald la
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice prima d'abord je
veux dire que comme vous le savez
lorsque le groupe f cfa chrysler s'est
présenté à renault pour cette
proposition d'alliance l'état
actionnaire de renault à hauteur de 15 %
l'a accueilli avec ouverture et à
travailler de manière constructive et
professionnelle avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes et je crois que c'est
ce qu'on est en droit d'attendre de tout
actionnaire au conseil d'administration
de renault
nous avons été évidemment en plus
soucieux des intérêts stratégiques de
l'industrie automobile française bruno
le maire avait immédiatement fixé quatre
conditions préalables qui seront de
toute éternité nécessaire à réunir si
d'autres dossiers de cette nature ou
différents devis se présenter à
l'approbation de l'opération par l'état
la première condition c'est la
réalisation de cette opération dans le
cadre de l'alliance entre renault et
nissan et donc sans ambiguïté si nous
avons un partenaire stratégique ou si
renault un partenaire stratégique qui
est nissan
il convient que cette alliance soit
respectée et que chacun soit à l'aise
autour de la table du conseil
d'administration c'est aussi la clé de
la réussite des vrais projets
industriels
la préservation des emplois industriels
et des sites industriels en france
deuxième condition une gouvernance
respectueuse des équilibres de renault
et de fc as et la participation de ce
futur ensemble industriel à l'initiative
des batteries électriques engagé avec
l'allemagne dans cette initiative est
également primordial pour l'avenir de
l'industrie automobile européenne
je vais dire qu'ici que des progrès
significatifs avaient été faits sur les
trois promus trois derniers éléments etc
et c'est la question d'un délai
additionnel là pour s'assurer du soutien
de l'ensemble des parties prenantes
notamment du soutien explicite de nissan
qui
amenez fc as a retiré son offre
l'état prend acte de cette décision je
crois que nous n'avons pas à rougir
d'avoir posé ses conditions qui étaient
de bon sens de bon aloi et professionnel
je le redis pour la suite
bruno le maire était présent au japon
ces derniers jours il a vu avec son
homologue japonais monsieur c'est cauet
peux vous garantir l'attachement de la
france et du japon à l'alliance ce sujet
était bien à l'agenda et nous allons
progresser je vous remercie